- DREW, COME FORWARD.
- YES, CHEF.
THIS IS A CHICKEN QUICHE
WITH CREMINI MUSHROOMS,
BABY SPINACH,
AND FETA CHEESE.
- UNBELIEVABLE.
WELL, DREW, I HAVE
A HUGE PROBLEM WITH THIS DISH.
[dramatic thud]
IT'S THAT YOU HAVEN'T
MADE IT FOR ME SOONER.
[upbeat music]
- THANK YOU, CHEF.
- BECAUSE IF YOU HAD,
DREW, THEN I WOULD KNOW
HOW GOOD YOU ARE
AT COOKING FOOD THAT'S BAD.
[dramatic thud,
suspenseful music]
- I'M SORRY, CHEF.
- AND WHEN I SAY, "BAD,"
I MEAN, MICHAEL JACKSON BAD.
[upbeat music]
- THANK YOU, CHEF.
- YOU KNOW HOW HE LOOKED
REALLY, REALLY BAD
AT THE END OF HIS LIFE?
[dramatic thud]
- CHEF, I'M SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
LIKE THE DISH OR NOT.
- YOU DON'T KNOW
IF I LIKE THE DISH OR NOT?
WELL,
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
PACK YOUR [bleep] KNIVES,
GET OUT, YOU'RE OFF THE SHOW.
- SORRY, CHEF.
- BECAUSE YOU SHOULD
BE WORKING
IN THE FINEST RESTAURANT
IN THE WORLD.
[upbeat music]
- THANK YOU, CHEF.
- JUST NOT ANY WORLD
THAT I LIVE IN.
[dramatic thud]
- SORRY, CHEF.
- BECAUSE, FRANKLY DREW,
I'M JEALOUS OF YOU.
- THANK YOU, CHEF.
- AND YOUR ABILITY
TO NOT GIVE A [bleep]
ABOUT WHAT YOU COOK.
THIS IS NOT FIT
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
NO, THIS SHOULD BE EATEN
BY A HIGHER LIFE-FORM
WITH A MORE COMPLEX PALATE,
BUT ALSO AN ALTRUISTIC DRIVE
TO SAVE HUMANITY
FROM DISHES LIKE THIS.
JOKING. NOT!
YOU DESERVE TO DIE!
AAH!
SO YOU WON'T HAVE TO ENDURE
A LIFE IN WHICH YOU WILL
NEVER EXCEED WHAT
YOU HAVE ACHIEVED HERE TODAY.
[upbeat music]
♪ ♪
- THANK YOU, CHEF.
- IN CONCLUSION...EH.
[buzzer]